I want to say a quick thing up top if
you're tuning in for news about the
Michigan primary I have two things to
say we tape early and we don't care okay
tapped into my audience perfectly right
there at the apathy the apathy crowd
they're there right we've got them
that's our demo in case you don't know
Romney and Santorum are neck-and-neck in
Michigan Mitt Romney has accused Rick
Santorum of saying outrageous things
just so Santorum can appeal to his most
extreme supporters yeah
now Santorum denied this and said that's
exactly the kind of misrepresentation
I'd expect from gay abortion doctor Mitt
Romney
[Applause]
google it it's true you know that Mitt
Romney for his campaign song MIT Romney
is using Kid Rock's born free yeah it's
much better than Romney's previous
choice born free thanks to a generous
inheritance sketchy so got some Oscar
fever going Andy oh I'm yeah I still
have a little bit of Oscar chills yeah
yeah little
Oscar diarrhea all right you never hear
about Oscar diarrhea you know but it's
it strikes many you never entertainment
tonight never talks about that who on
the red carpets got Oscar diarrhea yeah
all of Tinseltown has it that's my
impression of anybody on Entertainment
Tonight yeah I Brandt the Oscars for a
reason a lot of people are still
wondering if Jenner Paula Jennifer Lopez
had a nip slip during Sunday's Oscar
telecast well yeah a lot of people are
wondering the nipple has generated so
much excitement it's been asked to host
next year's show which I would watch by
the way a Glee absolutely standing
ovations at that nipple every time it
comes out who are you wearing nipple
yeah
[Laughter]
nice choice is choice nipple
[Applause]
[Music]
first time that's ever been said on
television
nice choice nipple we there more phrases
you'll hear for the first time here
we're good any other show you're gonna
like this one it's just a law of
averages the bottom he's got a hit a
sooner or later I'll wear him down the
CEO of Pizza Hut said that when he was
in college he used to bring his dates to
Pizza Hut yeah when asked where he
brought them on the second date he said
there were no second date
that's not a place where you seal the
deal really
hey a major new video game any gamers
here
[Applause]
the cruelest thing I do a major new
video game is coming up next month and
it's gonna let you choose to make your
character gay if you want yeah you can
make the character gay yeah so everyone
get ready for call of duty same-sex
booty
[Music]
whole new spin on Mario and Luigi in
Louisiana this is a true story a male
chimpanzee named Conan check this out is
still getting female chimps pregnant
despite the fact that he's already had
two vasectomies
thank you yeah thank you yeah yeah
according to zoo officials this chimp is
so incredibly virile and masculine
they've stopped calling him Conan
the tear made me strong